what's going to be different for people
as this this human thing you know that
the you will see the prime minister or
the other politicians within his cabinet
as real people as human beings you know
and I said we tend to kind of not see
politicians like that sometimes you know
quite rightly we don't see politicians
like them well now we will be shooting
it with Teresa may was wasn't Perla at
that point and she was going back and
forward to say Brussels I saw but I
exert business you know and you could
see you know that she was she was aging
by the day you know and because I was I
don't know however the felt a better had
a not being plain that that's part but
because I was I was looking at this
thinking she's just a person you know
she's really just a person at the end of
the day but um you see someone gonna
fall apart like that in front your eyes
I thought was quite sad you are giving
them a human face it's a sort in some
ways it's great payoff for politicians
this series isn't probably maybe it's
helping the motor no II you've been in
Canada for quite a long time now
and you're in some ways a bit of an
outsider looking it has been interesting
for me because I I've been I've been
away for the best part of ten years now
someone told me ten years ago
you know projected what was going to be
happening they said you're crazy you
know even though the people that are in
power are you didn't see him really sad
to see what's been happening you know
from a farm seen her divisive has been
divisive the politics has become and to
see how people are firm even people
within the same family fighting about
this thing this all but exit thing is
really gonna torn us apart as a nation
but also we have it in Scotland as well
it was very very closely walk with
independence in Scotland that referendum
and the effects that are still ongoing
you can unlock them to talk about it and
I'm reluctant to talk about it as well
to be honest with you because you come
down once a day the other you're gonna
get sorts of abuse from one side do you
want another referendum you know here's
the thing I'm really not the person to
ask that you know because I'm only one
person so is this
of course my opinion is valid as anyone
else but the problem when you're an
actor and you give your opinion as
you've got thousands of people are going
to kindy a fellow one where the other so
I'm going to be Switzerland there's this
case and I'm gonna say nothing yeah I
mean there's no way that I'd put myself
in that position I mean and also you can
fit your family in that position and
also so as a result you can attend not a
comment about it and I think it is true
for people in general you know there's
certainly people that in the public eye
you know it says so dangerous ain't it
they can be gone one way or the other
this show is also about with politics
and disaster but it's also as you've
said very human and talking about
juggling jobs and life and family and do
you feel like you've got it right in
your own life well you hope you know you
hope you know I've always tried to I've
always tried to keep myself separate
from public self you know I mean you
know I've very rarely do chat shows and
stuff like that I mean I can say that a
business isn't something that's never
really interested me I've never really
been interested in being you know a star
as well you know I mean I am NOT that
you know I don't believe I don't want to
be now and the most important thing to
me is has always been you know my family
has been the most important thing in my
life and anything that the trenches on
that or gets in the way or not you know
it's no good to me you know so you know
the Robert kalila is a different guy
evolved again I know and you've had huge
amounts of Fame that not least trains
for say I mean as that has that got
annoying over the years no I never gets
annoying you know it may be when it when
the first one came you know 120 years
ago whenever it was that was that was
kind of difficult if fostering cuz it
so actor I was back then as well you can
I think I am I'm more than that you can
I don't want to be seen it's just the
one thing you know but as the years went
by you know I've grown it to love Begbie
you know he's like no and that's the one
that that that it's technical people
know you from different things you know
people people in the street or obviously
all I loved you know sort of loved you
know whatever you know it's always
something different you know and but
Begbie is probably the one that if you
can unbalanced all out there's the one
that probably comes out on top